Your idea may be original but
it's more likely that your idea
is similar to ones that
have come before it.
To further validate your idea and
to determine if your product is
differentiated, you should
look at competitors.
First, you you'll need to know
who your competitors are.
You can quickly find
the competition by searching for
keywords related to your product idea.
You want to make sure you use words that
customers would use to describe your
product or something similar.
Seems like we have a couple competitors
in the news already, at least for
the grocery shopping app idea.
Once you've done that, you can collect
some basic info on the companies
using WHOis.net, Facebook, and Twitter.
Creation dates for
companies are listed on all three sites.
But do keep in mind that businesses
could have started even sooner.
On the WHOis.net,
the information is just below the fold.
Here's the information for Instacart.
You can find more information on your
competitors by going to websites
such as SimilarWeb and SEMrush.
You can either search for
websites or mobile apps.
On the results page, you can get
a sense for how the app is doing,
the traffic sources, and keywords that
people use to search for the app.
Now if we switch
the server to the website,
it will look a little bit different.
Here you can get a sense
of the traffic overview,
the geography of the traffic,
referring websites, search keywords,
including organic and paid, and social
referrals from different websites.
Other items you may be
considering looking into,
include the competitors'
social media interactions.
What are they writing about, and
how are customers talking about
the brand or the product?
If you're iterating on your product, or
trying to understand other companies'
value propositions, then I encourage you
to look at their own homepages and
landing pages for specific products.